hallo ihr lieben wie heftig ist das denn
bitte das jahr 2018 ist schon fast zu
ende heute kommt das allerletzte video
für dieses jahr auf einem kanal online
und es dreht sich alles um silvester wir
machen nämlich zwei rezepte zu
fingerfood superschnell und easy
hergestellt und ist sich aufgefallen ich
habe heute meine fledermaus oberteil an
schon beim letzten mal ist es deutlich
hier die hose gegangen du guckst du doch
gar nicht an muss ich auch mal gucken ob
ich weiß es deutlich in die hose
gegangen das video werde ich euch in
infobox verlegen das waren nämlich das
als ich meiner geburtstagstorte gebacken
hat und warum ich das in die infobox
verlinke viele habe ich auf die regel
baki ich mache deine geburtstagstorte
mit wunderkerzen drin zu silvester weil
sie so festlich aussieht und da habe ich
mir gedacht zudem anders mache ich noch
mal die challenge sie dieses oberteil an
und werde am ende des videos sehen ob
ich es voll eingebaut habe hierbei man
ein video oder nicht aber jetzt kommt
erstmal zehn rezepten die ich mache und
zwar es gibt zwei rezepte das erstes
sind blätterteig reise mit tomate super
lecker und das zweite das ist vielleicht
ein bisschen old school aber wir machen
mozzarella tomaten spieße aber noch ein
bisschen aufgepimpt das zeige ich euch
gleich wie die stadt jetzt erstmal mit
dem blätterteig rezept dafür benötigen
wir blätterteig außerdem tomaten die
habe ich mittelgroße genommen creme
fraiche oder schmand an gewürzen
erotisches paprikapulver kräuter der
provence hier habe ich selbst und
knoblauch und optional ein ei zu kümmern
wir uns jetzt zuallererst um die creme
ich habe ziele wie gesagt creme fraiche
genommen haben schnell wieder davon
abstand nehmen kann weiß ich gar nicht
mehr aber ich sag sie sich halt weil die
frage bestimmt aufkommen wird und jetzt
gehen wir einfach die gewürze und die
knoblauchzehe da rein und verrühren das
[Musik]
so die creme wäre damit fertig und jetzt
nehmen uns im blätterteig ich habe steve
kühlkette teilgenommen und den antauen
lassen wir können auch den aus dem
kühlregal nehmen das ist vollkommen euch
überlassen und jetzt schneiden wir oder
stechen und kreise aus die sollen ein
bisschen größer sondern ist die tomate
tapezierten ausstecher ich bin mir aber
fast schon sicher dass man das muss da
gar nicht mehr sehen wird aber wir
nehmen jetzt einfach dass wir können
natürlich sonst auch ein glas nehmen
habe ich gestern zb so gemacht
[Musik]
so ich habe die blätterteig kreise jetzt
immer schon direkt auf ein mit
backpapier ausgelegtes backblech gelegt
und den verschnitt bloß nicht
wegschmeißen einfach zusammen kneten
irgendwann mittel wieder geschmeidig und
dann rollen wir ihn aus und stechen uns
wieder kreis aus aber jetzt machen wir
die hier erstmal zu ende und dafür
schneide ich jetzt die tomaten in
scheiben
[Musik]
die tomaten habe ich jetzt in scheiben
geschnitten halben zentimeter dick und
soll euch überlassen
ja ach ja ja ist klar so muss ich mal
nach ob das wirklich ein halbes
jahr hat sag ich doch alles zurück nicht
genug bist du großer klappe nichts
dahinter bei dir
weiter geht's
so und jetzt gehen wir immer ein klecks
von unserer krähen auf die blätterteig
kreise und verteilen ist mit dem löffel
so ganz grob
[Musik]
sobald ihr dann die creme drauf
verstrichen abgibt de tomatenscheiben
obendrauf und ihr könnt ihr auch noch
mal so ganz leicht andrücken
so als nächstes werde ich das will und
das ist jetzt einfach nur für die optik
also geschmackliche sitz hat es nichts
zu tun aber es sieht dann einfach immer
so ein bisschen schöner und schön
gebräunt aus
[Musik]
und jetzt kommt die erste ladung
blätterteig tomaten innen rufen achtung
ganz wichtig er muss vorgeheizt seien
auf 200 grad oberen unterricht sondern
dort das ganze ungefähr 20 bis 22
minuten und dann machen wir so lange
weiter mit dem anderen rezept und jetzt
zweites machen wir die tomaten
mozzarella spieße die gehen so schnell
dass wir jetzt einfach in der
zwischenzeit machen während das andere
rezepte offen ist und ich zeige ich
jetzt erstmal die wenigen zutaten dafür
und zwar sind das olivenöl petersilie
cherry tomaten mit mozzarella frischem
basilikum und wir brauchen noch kleine
stäbchen also natürlich spies und nicht
stäbchen oder kleine zahnstocher sagt da
haben wir gerade würde auch gehen falls
er solche jetzt nicht herbekommt und wir
machen das jetzt so dass wir die
mozzarellas ein bisschen aufpimpen weil
so ist ja langweilig und dafür gehen wir
jetzt zuallererst petersilie und
olivenöl in einer schüssel und verrühren
das miteinander
beim olivenöl mich einfach aufpassen
dass wir nicht zu viel nicht zu wenig
rein gibt es soll so eine paste artige
konsistenz haben und ich gebe mal nach
und nach immer ein bisschen petersilie
und olivenöl dazu damit sich auch später
nichts verschwendet und jetzt gebe ich
die mozzarella kugeln rein und dann
mache ich das am liebsten mit den
sauberen händen dass ich ein bisschen
darin wälzen und damit das schön haften
bleibt
[Musik]
so die mozzarella kügelchen sind fertig
des wortes einzige was wir uns
vorbereiten mussten die cherrytomaten
habe ich nur halbiert und jetzt stießen
wir auf und nochmal ganz kurzer hinweis
falls ihr petersilie nicht mögt dann
tauscht aus durch zb freien märkten
basilikum falls ihr olivenöl nicht mögt
dann nimmt einfach sonnenblumenöl oder
irgendein öl was ihr mut und ihr könnt
auch gerne fertiges pesto verwenden ist
auch nur super idee so jetzt fange ich
auch erstmal mit dem mozilla kugeln und
dann schließlich das schritt für schritt
einfach auf
[Musik]
die tomaten mozzarella spieße sind somit
fertig ohne zwischenzeit hat der ofen
gibt und es steht alles bereit auf dem
tisch und ihr könnt die spieße wenn ihr
möchtet jetzt noch etwas salzen wenn das
salz erneut und euch das salz im
mozzarella reicht dann lass es einfach
so ich geh jetz auch so ein bisschen
salz oben drüber und das könnt ihr super
vorbereiten also die spieße könnt ihr
gerne am vorabend schon vorbereiten und
im kühlschrank lagern beim letzter tag
würde ich so machen dass ihr das
wirklich frisch zubereitet und schmeckt
sich am allerbesten
[Musik]
so und jetzt hoffe ich natürlich dass er
das ganze woche nach macht das ist jetzt
wirklich lastminute und man kann es noch
am gleichen tag zu bereiten und brauche
auch nicht so lange in der küche stehen
kann sich um die anderen dinge kümmern
die genauen mengenangaben stehen wie
immer hier unten in der infobox ich
freue mich wenn ihr dem video ein
dörfchen nach oben gibt wünsche euch
natürlich einen guten rutsch ins neue
jahr und schreib mir doch gerne mal eure
vorsätze ich habe ehrlich gesagt keine
wirklichen vorsätzlich versucht einfach
so weiterzumachen
genauer das natürlich also wir haben
sich viele pläne für 2010 an den online
shop in den umzug die hochzeitsfeier
aber wir haben ein bisschen das bloggen
für uns entdecken euch gefällt es auch
ganz gut daher werdet ihr auf jeden fall
immer top aktuell informiert sind und
knapp dass ich nicht dreckig geworden
bin alles sauber geblieben bei den
beispielen rezept ging das aber auch
echt gut so ansonsten wünsche ich euch
jetzt noch einen wunderschönen tag und
wir sehen uns dann im neuen jahr